I had no idea that it was rotates all the way down. And so if you think about it, how do you get a stable sort in place? Well, that's a quick sort with a stable partition. How do you do stable partition? That's just rotate called recursively. How do you do a rotate? That's just three reverses. how do you do reverses that's just swap and so so we just built like some of the most complex algorithms in 20 seconds right it's really beautiful people should in general think about and there's multiple algorithms in that kind of sort hierarchy right so stable sort is at the top then sort and partition and then element you know there's a partial sort might be in there but
我完全没想到它竟然是一层层旋转下去的。如果你仔细想想，如何在原地实现稳定排序？其实就是带稳定分区的快速排序。如何实现稳定分区？那只是递归调用旋转。如何实现旋转？那只是三次反转。如何实现反转？那只是交换。所以我们刚才在20秒内就构建了一些最复杂的算法，这真的很美妙。人们通常应该思考一下，在那种排序层级中存在多种算法，对吧？所以稳定排序处于顶端，然后是排序和分区，接着是元素，你知道，可能还有部分排序在里面，但是
there's a there's a range of power there right and we should be picking the least powerful thing to solve the problem in general yes the fastest algorithm is usually the one with the with the fewest guarantees people tend to to use a shotgun where a scalpel would suffice welcome to adsp the podcast episode 203 recorded on september 26 2004 my name is connor and today with my co-host ben we continue our conversation with sean parent about stood rotate we talk about how it lays the foundation for stable sort, talk about many other algorithms and more. Interesting. So we've got std rotate and GCD.
这里有一系列的能力范围，对吧？我们通常应该选择最不强大的工具来解决问题。是的，最快的算法通常是保证最少的那个。人们倾向于用霰弹枪，而手术刀其实就足够了。欢迎收听ADSP播客第203集，录制于2004年9月26日。我是Connor，今天和我的联合主持人Ben一起，我们继续与Sean Parent关于std::rotate的对话。我们讨论了它如何为稳定排序奠定基础，还谈到了许多其他算法等等。很有趣。所以我们有std::rotate和GCD。
They have an intertwined history. I'm not sure if you know this off the top of your head, because I have also not read, although a good friend of mine on top of you has also, I think he tried to read EOP and was a C++ dev for a while, but now is mostly using Python. And he transitioned very quickly to mathematics, from mathematics to generic programming and said that it was a much easier read, but also like more thoroughly enjoyable because of the the way that the content is given to the reader does that book cover the three different implementations of rotate or i'll have to
它们有着交织的历史。我不确定你是否能脱口而出，因为我也没读过，尽管我的一位好朋友读过，我想他曾尝试阅读《编程要素》（EOP），并且做过一段时间的C++开发，但现在主要使用Python。他很快从数学转向了泛型编程，并说那本书读起来容易得多，而且因为内容呈现给读者的方式，读起来也更彻底地令人愉悦。那本书涵盖了旋转的三种不同实现吗？还是我必须……
just you know i it should be i don't know if i can make it a 2024 goal but 2025 goal will be to get through all these videos read eop and read from mathematics to generic programming otherwise you know it's i can't can't have this happening again where I, at the end of an episode, am apologizing for probably only 80% of what we should have been apologizing for. We didn't know how little we knew. I mean, Bryce has less of an excuse
你知道，我不知道这能不能成为2024年的目标，但2025年的目标一定要读完所有这些视频，读完《编程要素》，读完《从数学到泛型编程》。否则，你知道，我不能再让这种情况发生了：在节目结束时，我还在为我们本该道歉的80%的内容而道歉。我们当时不知道自己有多无知。我是说，Bryce的借口更少，
because he's purportedly read EOP. So I don't know, he dropped the ball there. I can admit more ignorance and say ashamedly that I haven't actually even finished it. So at least I didn't fail to recall it. I'm not sure which is worse. I mean, there was a time when if you went to C++ Now, the first thing you would hear would be read Elements of Programming. The first year I went to C++ Now was 2014. That was where i first heard about
因为他据说是读过《编程要素》的。所以我不知道，他在那方面掉链子了。我可以承认更多的无知，并羞愧地说我实际上甚至还没读完它。所以至少我没有记错。我不确定哪个更糟。我是说，曾经有一段时间，如果你去参加C++ Now大会，你听到的第一件事就是“去读《编程要素》”。我第一次参加C++ Now是2014年，那是我第一次听说
elements of programming the next year when i went back i had read elements of programming so i was ready for c++ now in a sense yeah i yeah i think well i mean since you guys talk a lot about stl algorithms uh not always but if you're if you're trying to to research one of the stl algorithms where where it's it's one of the the ones that came out of the the steppanoff library right steppanoff and lee check eop first if it isn't there go to steppanoff papers and there's a oh i can find the exact links for you there's's a couple of near books. I think one of them is called Notes on Programming and one is called Programming as Mathematics. Those were drafts of what eventually became EOP.
《编程要素》。第二年我回去时，我已经读过《编程要素》了，所以在某种意义上，我已经为C++ Now做好了准备。是的，我想，既然你们经常谈论STL算法，呃，不总是这样，但如果你试图研究其中一个STL算法，它是出自Stepanov库的那种，对吧？Stepanov和Lee，先查《编程要素》。如果那里没有，就去查Stepanov的论文。哦，我可以为你找到确切的链接，有几本相关的书。我想其中一本叫《编程笔记》，另一本叫《作为数学的编程》。那些是最终成为《编程要素》的草稿。
They're in some ways more approachable. They're more algorithmic centered, less math, even a little less philosophical. When you say Notes on Programming, are you, because I'm pretty sure, at least when you say that, I think of the 88 page PDF that is written or the language used in it. I'm not sure if there's multiple, but one of them for sure is scheme. Is this the same thing you're thinking of? Because there's a chance then if that was a starting point for EOP, maybe EOP all this time, and it's my fault for not having fully read it,
它们在某些方面更容易接近。它们更以算法为中心，数学成分较少，甚至哲学成分也较少。当你提到《编程笔记》时，你是说……因为我很确定，至少当你提到这个时，我想到的是那份88页的PDF，或者其中使用的语言。我不确定是否有多个版本，但其中一个肯定是Scheme。这是你所想的那个吗？因为如果那是《编程要素》的起点，那么也许《编程要素》一直以来……这是我的错，因为我没有完全读完它，
maybe it mentions APL because famously the notes on programming that I'm thinking of implements Reduce and I think all the other algorithms in Scheme. And it mentions, that was the first time I had heard a reference to the fact that Stepanov borrowed the name Reduce from APL and basically said that's where he first saw that algorithm. Yeah, let me see. Links, of course, dear listener, will be in the show notes. I also, sadly, even though I have referenced in both podcasts and talks, the notes on programming, have not fully read that 88-page PDF.
也许它提到了APL，因为众所周知，我所想的那份《编程笔记》实现了Reduce，我想还有Scheme中的所有其他算法。它提到，那是第一次我听到有人提到Stepanov从APL借用了Reduce这个名字，并基本上说那是他第一次看到那个算法的地方。是的，让我看看。链接，当然，亲爱的听众，会在节目说明中。我也很遗憾，尽管我在播客和演讲中都引用过《编程笔记》，但我还没有完全读完那份88页的PDF。
I have read through some of it. Right. So if you go to steppingoffpapers.com, and then the two things I'm referring to are under Class Notes and Videos, there's a section that says, Incomplete Notes for the Foundation of Programming Course Taught at Adobe, May 2004. And there's a pdf for that and if you open that pdf it's uh the title of it is foundations of programming i think volume one linear structures and so that was the start of what was going to become come EOP and then Alex was having
我读过其中的一部分。对。所以如果你去steppingoffpapers.com，我提到的那两样东西在“课堂笔记和视频”下，有一个部分写着“2004年5月在Adobe教授的编程基础课程的不完整笔记”。那里有一个PDF，如果你打开那个PDF，它的标题是《编程基础，第一卷：线性结构》，那就是后来成为《编程要素》的起点。然后Alex当时
a difficult time kind of completing that that work partially because he just is somebody who goes off on a lot of tangents and so Matt Marcus jumped in to help and so if you look the next thing on the page is steppinganoff and Matt Marcus notes for the Foundations of Programming course, 2004-2005, and it's split into three sections, mathematical preliminaries, generic programming, and the partition algorithm. And those three sections sections form the complete draft of a book. Okay. So we had finished the draft of the book. And there were a number of things that Alex wasn't happy about. Alex and Matt got into a bit of an argument over the direction and how things should be shaken out. And Alex actually pulled out of the effort and said he was going to go do it himself. And so he started again, page one, a rewrite. And
在完成那项工作时遇到了一些困难，部分原因是他是一个容易跑题的人，所以Matt Marcus跳出来帮忙。所以如果你看页面上的下一项，是Stepanov和Matt Marcus的《编程基础课程笔记，2004-2005》，它分为三个部分：数学预备知识、泛型编程和分区算法。这三个部分构成了书的完整草稿。好的。所以我们完成了书的草稿。Alex对其中一些事情不满意。Alex和Matt在方向和如何处理这些事情上发生了一些争执。Alex实际上退出了这项工作，并说他要自己做。于是他从第一页开始重写。而且
soon after he started, Paul McJones joined him. And so it was that effort that led to EOP. But the notes for the Foundations of of programming and Alex's notes before that cover most of the algorithms that are in the classic STL in a fair amount of detail with all the proper references, right? It's not like, you know, Alex invented this stuff. There's very little in STL that's new. It's collecting other people's work and putting it into a generic form it's the generic aspect that's the new aspect of it well uh sorry actually i want i want to ask you is so stable sort is new right stable sort in knuth edition 2 was listed as a research problem i believe yeah it's a problem that took in place stable sort
在他开始后不久，Paul McJones加入了。正是那次努力促成了《编程要素》。但是《编程基础》的笔记以及Alex之前的笔记涵盖了经典STL中的大多数算法，并带有所有适当的引用，相当详细，对吧？并不是说，你知道，Alex发明了这些东西。STL中几乎没有什么新东西。它只是收集了别人的工作并将其转化为泛型形式。泛型方面才是它的新颖之处。好吧，呃，抱歉，其实我想问你的是，稳定排序是新的，对吧？Knuth第2版中将稳定排序列为一个研究问题，我相信。是的，这是一个需要原地稳定排序的问题。
yeah in situ stable sort is is alex's big algorithmic contribution there and that's um in older versions of the art of computer programming which is knuth's book uh uh it was listed as an exercise and the exercises have a difficulty problem and i forget what the scale is it's like like five or something is is basically it's a knuth scale m50 is ringing a bell for some reason i think that's like the take a grad student and give them a couple of years to solve it something like that yes so it's basically an exercise with no known solution. And stable partition in STL is an in-place solution and depends on rotate. So it's really quite amazingly trivial once you understand, which is, you know, if you want to do a stable partition for the reader, what that means is you've got some predicate that's going to return true or false.
是的，原地稳定排序是Alex的主要算法贡献，那是……在Knuth的书《计算机程序设计艺术》的旧版本中，它被列为一道练习题，而且练习题有难度等级，我忘了那个等级是什么了，大概是5之类的。基本上是Knuth的等级。M50不知为何让我有印象，我想那大概是“找个研究生，给他们几年时间去解决它”之类的意思。是的，所以它基本上是一个没有已知解的练习题。而STL中的稳定分区是一个原地解决方案，并且依赖于rotate。所以一旦你理解了，它其实相当简单，也就是说，如果你想为读者做一个稳定分区，这意味着你有一个谓词，它会返回真或假。
And you want to reorder your sequence so that all the true guys are first, and then all the false guys follow. But the relative order of everything in the true bucket and everything in the false bucket doesn't change. And you want to do that in place with some reasonable complexity. And so the algorithm is, well, if you imagine somehow magically, what if our sequence was stable partitioned on half and the other half was stable partitioned on half, and the other half was stable partitioned, just somehow magically. And I wanted to combine those so that the whole was stable partitioned. Well, what you want to do is you want to take
你想重新排序你的序列，使得所有为真的元素排在前面，然后所有为假的元素跟在后面。但是真桶和假桶中所有元素的相对顺序不会改变。而且你想以合理的复杂度原地完成。所以算法是，好吧，如果你能以某种方式想象，如果我们的序列在前半部分稳定分区，后半部分也稳定分区，只是以某种神奇的方式。而我想把它们结合起来，使整体实现稳定分区。好吧，你想做的是
the two adjoining parts in the middle and rotate them. And now the whole is stable partitioned. And so then you can just keep recursively dividing each half until you get down to just one element, in which case, how do you stable partition one element? Well, you're just returning the partition point, which is you're just going to return... Whether or not it satisfies the predicate plus its place.
把中间相邻的两个部分旋转一下。现在整体就实现了稳定分区。所以你可以不断递归地平分每一半，直到只剩下一个元素，在这种情况下，如何对一个元素进行稳定分区？好吧，你只是返回分区点，也就是你只是要返回……它是否满足谓词，加上它的位置。
Yeah. Right, plus its address. So that's trivial. Once you recurse all the way down, now you can build it back up by just rotating. Okay. And that gives you an n log n complexity algorithm for doing an in situ stable partition. And so, you know, an in situ stable partition gives you an in situ stable sort. And so if you think about it, how do you get a stable sort in place? Well, that's a quick sort with a stable partition. How do you do stable partition? That's just rotate called recursively. How do you do a rotate? That's just three reverses. How do you do reverses? That's just swap. And so we just built some of the most complex algorithms in 20 seconds, right? It's really beautiful.
是的。对，加上它的地址。所以这很简单。一旦你递归到底部，现在你就可以通过旋转把它重新构建起来。这给了你一个n log n复杂度的原地稳定分区算法。所以，你知道，原地稳定分区给了你一个原地稳定排序。所以如果你想一想，如何原地实现稳定排序？好吧，那是一个带稳定分区的快速排序。如何实现稳定分区？那只是递归调用rotate。如何实现rotate？那只是三次反转。如何实现反转？那只是交换。所以我们刚才在20秒内就构建了一些最复杂的算法，对吧？这真的很美妙。
And people say that the STL algorithms are not composable. They're incredibly composable. So in fact, almost every algorithm that's in the original STL, the reason why it's there is because it was a building block for stable sort. So that's it. That's the beauty. I had no idea that it was rotates all the way down. In the back of my head now, I've been thinking where it's almost unfathomable that I've made such a big deal. At one point, I actually wanted to get the APL rotate symbol as a tattoo.
人们说STL算法不可组合。它们是极其可组合的。事实上，几乎每一个原始STL中的算法，它存在的原因就是因为它是稳定排序的构建块。所以就是这样。这就是美妙之处。我完全没想到它竟然是一层层旋转下去的。现在在我的脑海里，我一直在想，我竟然把它看得这么重要，这简直不可思议。有一次，我甚至想把APL的旋转符号纹在身上。
And then I had this whole plan to like reveal it during a talk. Anyways, I have a very, very soft place in my heart for the rotate algorithm because i feel like it that was like watching that talk however many years ago you know almost it's like you have these inflection points in your career and uh that was like a big one and now here we are four years later episode you know 202 of this podcast where rotate has come up this many times and i feel like we only on this podcast had touched like the tip of the rotate iceberg, but not only just on this podcast, like also in the conference, like circuits, like there is this beautiful talk that I may give in the future, or maybe someone else will beat me to it.
然后我有一个完整的计划，想在演讲中揭示它。总之，我对rotate算法有着非常非常深厚的感情，因为我觉得那就像……观看那场演讲，无论多少年前，你知道，几乎就像你职业生涯中的转折点，而那是一个很大的转折点。现在四年过去了，在这个播客的第202集，rotate已经出现了这么多次，我觉得我们在这个播客上只是触及了rotate冰山的一角，而且不仅是在这个播客上，在会议上也是，比如电路，有一个非常漂亮的演讲，我将来可能会做，或者别人可能会抢先。
That is just titled stood colon, colon rotate that like talks about like these implementations and talks about elements of programming, unless if maybe in the hundred hours of content of the four algorithmic journeys, these algorithms are talked about. Cause like similar to your C++ seasoning talk, Sean, where you have those beautiful animations building up to what you ended up calling gather, you could show basically the exact same kind of animations talking about the rotate algorithm, but I have in the thousand plus talks I've watched in the last N years,
标题就是std::rotate，它谈论了这些实现，谈论了《编程要素》，除非在四次算法之旅的百小时内容中，这些算法已经被讨论过了。因为就像你关于C++ Seasoning的演讲一样，Sean，你有那些漂亮的动画，构建出你最终称之为gather的东西，你可以展示几乎完全相同的动画来谈论rotate算法，但我在这N年里观看的一千多场演讲中，
I've never seen that in any, not just C++, but there's also some Swift talks out there by Dave Abrahams and Doug Greger and other talks in different languages. I've never seen anything touches on this. So yeah, what's going on? How come this talk doesn't exist? Or maybe it doesn't.
我从来没见过任何触及这个话题的演讲，不仅是C++，还有Dave Abrahams和Doug Gregor的一些Swift演讲，以及其他语言的演讲。我从来没见过任何触及这个话题的内容。所以，到底是怎么回事？为什么这个演讲不存在？或者也许它确实存在。
It just hasn't come across my radar. I don't know one quite like that that exists. But yeah, I think if you did like title of talk stood rotate and you can get into kind of the algorithmic beauty and then the uses, both the uses inside of STL and things like slide and then gather. Ben's example of picking up one element and putting it somewhere else. Actually, when you said that, I was like, that's not a rotate.
只是没进入我的视野。我不知道有哪个完全像那样的演讲存在。但是，是的，我想如果你做一个标题为“std::rotate”的演讲，你可以深入探讨算法之美，然后是用途，包括在STL内部的用途，以及像slide和gather这样的东西。Ben关于拾取一个元素并把它放到别处的例子。其实，当你这么说的时候，我当时想，那不是rotate。
And I was like, oh, no, that is a one rotate. This is overwhelmingly the most common use case I've ever seen for rotate. People do this all the time. Arbitrarily rotating blocks or ranges ranges that's a useful building block but but in application code 90% of the time you want to take this element and put it somewhere else yeah i'm not sure that a rotate lies behind that animation but any i can think in like a multiple apps on my phone where you'll have a, basically some form of a playlist or some form of a list. And then you have like a hamburger thing that you
然后我想，哦，不，那是一个“1-rotate”。这是我见过的rotate最常见的用例，压倒性地常见。人们一直在做这个。任意旋转块或范围，这是有用的构建块，但在应用程序代码中，90%的情况下，你是想拿走这个元素并把它放到别处。是的，我不确定rotate是否是那个动画背后的逻辑，但我能想到我手机上的多个应用，你会有某种形式的播放列表或列表。然后你有一个类似汉堡包的东西，你可以
can touch and like drag the UI thing. Even if there's no rotate in the code behind the scenes, cause you're actually doing a little bit more, right? As soon as you touch it, I guess, technically you're just doing repeated one rotates on two elements, but you can drag it up and down. And that is effectively at the end of the day, if you're not showing that animation, that's a one rotate on that sequence whenever you're doing that kind of. And I think that's not that far removed from the gather example that Sean shows where I think you kind of talk about what if you're in like an email inbox or something like that and you you select two things and or I can't remember if that was your exact example but it is something to do with that well my exact example I was working on Chrome OS and and and I was doing my very first code review at Google and somebody made a change so that you could Chrome OS has a view where you could could could see all of your windows as kind of these little slices on your screen, and you could reorder your windows. And you could only drag one, right?
触摸并拖动UI元素。即使幕后的代码中没有rotate，因为你实际上做得更多，对吧？一旦你触摸它，我想，技术上你只是在两个元素上重复进行1-rotate，但你可以上下拖动它。归根结底，如果你没有展示那个动画，当你做那种操作时，那对该序列来说就是一个1-rotate。而且我认为这与Sean展示的gather例子相差不远，我想你谈到了如果你在电子邮件收件箱之类的东西里，你选择了两个东西，或者我不记得那是不是你的确切例子，但它确实与此有关。好吧，我的确切例子是我在Chrome OS工作时，我在谷歌进行第一次代码审查，有人做了一个改动，这样Chrome OS有一个视图，你可以把所有的窗口看作屏幕上的小切片，你可以重新排列你的窗口。而且你只能拖动一个，对吧？
You could drag one and put it in. And that's the code that I was reviewing. And the code, I show all the code in my talk, It's this morass of loops. It's like this 1800 line function or something like that that's doing all of these loops. And a bunch of them are conditionalized like, oh well
你可以拖动一个并把它放进去。那就是我正在审查的代码。代码，我在演讲中展示了所有的代码，它是一团循环。它是一个1800行的函数之类的东西，正在做所有这些循环。而且其中一堆是条件化的，比如，哦，好吧，
in this case we do this loop, in that case we do this loop, in this other case we do this other loop. And I was like, whenever I do code review the first thing I look at is what are the loops? What in the world are these things doing right and i tear through it and they're doing a one rotate and they're doing it by erasing the one element and then erasing the next element and and reinserting it into the new slot so it's like this quadratic erase and assert mess okay and so it's really slow and and the only other piece of it was you needed to find the position right you user clicks somewhere you
在这种情况下我们做这个循环，在那种情况下我们做那个循环，在另一种情况下我们做另一个循环。我当时想，每当我做代码审查时，我首先看的是循环是什么？这些东西到底在做什么？我仔细研究了一下，它们在做一个1-rotate，而且它们是通过擦除一个元素，然后擦除下一个元素，并把它重新插入到新的槽位中来完成的，所以这就像是一个二次方的擦除和插入混乱。好的，所以它非常慢，而且它唯一剩下的部分是你需要找到位置，对吧？用户点击某处，你
need to find the position and and so so i went went and said okay like the start of this is a find if followed by rotate and if you read all of the rest rest of it, it's basically just another rotate, which is what gather is because you're rotating. Depending on which way you're moving, you're rotating one direction or the other, right? It's the same three arguments, just a different permutation of the same three arguments. So I'm like, this is just find if, rotate. That's all that's happening here. And that had led to a big argument. And I finally convinced the, uh, uh, the author of the code that, that yes, that's what his code was actually doing. I mean, the first thing was, he's like, no, that's not at all. You don't understand my code, right? My
需要找到位置。所以我就说，好吧，这个的开始是一个find_if，后面跟着rotate。如果你读了剩下的所有内容，它基本上只是另一个rotate，这就是gather，因为你在旋转。根据你移动的方向，你向一个方向或另一个方向旋转，对吧？它是相同的三个参数，只是相同三个参数的不同排列。所以我说，这只是find_if，rotate。这就是这里发生的一切。这导致了一场大争论。我最终说服了代码的作者，是的，他的代码实际上就是在做这个。我是说，第一件事是，他说，不，根本不是。你不懂我的代码，对吧？我的
code is doing way more than that. And I'm like, it's doing that, right? It's doing a lot more work to do that, but right. Right. So I finally convinced the author, but then it was still rejected from the code review because my mentor, who was overseeing, since it was my first code review, said that it was too tricky and nobody knew what Rotate did. And because of that, that code landed in the Chromium open sourced effort because Chrome OS is open sourced under Chromium. And that's why I was able to put the code in my slides. Okay?
代码做的远不止这些。我说，它就是在做这个，对吧？它为了做这个做了更多的工作，但对。对。所以我最终说服了作者，但它仍然被代码审查拒绝了，因为我的导师，他负责监督，因为这是我的第一次代码审查，他说这太棘手了，没人知道Rotate是做什么的。正因为如此，那段代码进入了Chromium开源项目，因为Chrome OS是在Chromium下开源的。这就是为什么我能把代码放进我的幻灯片里。好的？
Nice. So that's kind of the whole arc. And my point there is, once you realize that that's a one rotate, then if you want to do multiple selection and select a range, that's still just a rotate. And if you want to do a disjoint selection, it's stable partition. But stable partition is just recursive rotates. Right.
不错。所以这就是整个弧线。我的观点是，一旦你意识到那是一个1-rotate，那么如果你想进行多选并选择一个范围，那仍然只是一个rotate。如果你想进行不连续的选择，那就是稳定分区。但稳定分区只是递归的rotate。对。
So once you realize what you're doing is a rotate, you can do multiple selections in your ui okay trivially yeah because it's all built from the same stuff because it's all built from the same stuff if your code though is is looking like like well if it's at this position then i'm going to erase this guy and insert these guys and and otherwise i'm going to erase this guy and insert those guys if that's how your code's written first you're going to go horribly quadratic as you try to extend it to more to more elements but you're also never going to erase this guy and insert those guys. If that's how your code's written, first you're going to go horribly quadratic as you try to extend it to more elements, but you're also never going to figure it out. The complexity gets too high to think about it in those terms. So my pet peeve right now is applications that don't support multiple select, or if they do support multiple select, don't let me drag the selection around. Right?
所以一旦你意识到你在做的是一个rotate，你就可以在你的UI中轻松地进行多选。好的，是的，因为它们都是用同样的东西构建的。因为它们都是用同样的东西构建的。如果你的代码看起来像，好吧，如果它在这个位置，那么我要擦除这个家伙并插入这些家伙，否则我要擦除这个家伙并插入那些家伙，如果你的代码是这样写的，首先当你试图扩展到更多元素时，你会变得极其缓慢，而且你永远也不会弄明白。复杂度变得太高，无法用这些术语来思考。所以我现在的痛点是那些不支持多选的应用程序，或者如果它们支持多选，不让我拖动选择。对吧？
Drives me insane. And it's ubiquitous. All right. I know we only have a couple minutes left because we have a hard stop. We have to let you go, Sean. But maybe in the last couple minutes, a final question. And it might be hard to answer now. So if there's no answer, maybe we can all just think about it and see if we can come up for answers next time. I, just in the last 60 minutes, just during this recording, realized that the one rotate is actually like the most common use case of a rotate.
让我抓狂。而且它无处不在。好的。我知道我们只剩下几分钟了，因为我们有硬性截止时间。我们必须让你走，Sean。但也许在最后几分钟，最后一个问题。现在可能很难回答。所以如果没有答案，也许我们都可以思考一下，看看下次能不能想出答案。我，就在过去60分钟，就在这次录音期间，意识到1-rotate实际上是rotate最常见的用例。
That's like lying in plain sight. But until you, someone says it or you notice it, I do kind of like, you know, I have a soft spot in my heart, like I said, said for for rotate but you do kind of think of this like oh whoever needs like a four rotate it doesn't come up that often but a one rotate when you think about it from like what's what is that doing that comes up all the time are there other either stl algorithms or algorithms outside of the stl that have these obvious like in plain sight use cases that, you know, might, I might be missing or folks might be missing. Cause like, I think stood sort, you know, algorithms like that, it's obvious what you use those for, but potentially I'm guessing that there are these other kinds of uses in plain sight that until you see it, you might miss. Do you have any of those
这就像躺在显眼的地方。但直到有人说出来或者你注意到它，我确实有点，你知道，我像我说的那样，对rotate情有独钟，但你确实会想，哦，谁需要4-rotate呢？它不常出现。但当你从它在做什么的角度思考1-rotate时，它一直都在出现。还有其他STL算法或STL之外的算法有这些显而易见的、在显眼处的用例吗？你知道，我可能错过了，或者人们可能错过了。因为，我想std::sort，你知道，像这样的算法，使用它们的目的很明显，但我猜测可能还有其他这种在显眼处的用途，直到你看到它，你可能会错过。你有任何这样的
off the top of your head or? Yeah, I think, you know, my, my other favorite algorithm that gets missed a lot is nth element. I was going to say the same thing. Least appreciated, the most underappreciated algorithm ever. Yes. So nth element, I mean, it will give you a median. It will give you, you know, so it's very useful if you're trying to gather statistics on things. It will give you unsorted top n.
脱口而出的例子吗？或者？是的，我想，你知道，我另一个经常被错过的最喜欢的算法是nth_element。我正要说同样的话。最不受重视，有史以来最被低估的算法。是的。所以nth_element，我的意思是，它会给你一个中位数。它会给你，你知道，所以如果你试图收集事物的统计数据，它非常有用。它会给你未排序的前n个。
Yeah, if you need the top n elements out of something, or not just the top n, if you need a window of things, you need things, you need elements 30 to 50 out of a sequence of a million. How do you get that without sorting the whole sequence? So nth element is going to be a piece of that answer. It also partitions, it leaves your sequence partitioned. And so that's a very useful property that can be exploited. And so if you're trying to gather a range of statistics, like if you're in graphics and you want the, you don't just want the media and you want like, like what's at the 10% mark, the 40% mark, the 50%, the 90%, right? You want to sample a set of crust of ranges. You can do that by starting at the nth element
是的，如果你需要某样东西的前n个元素，或者不仅仅是前n个，如果你需要一个窗口，你需要元素，你需要一百万个序列中的第30到50个元素。如何在不排序整个序列的情况下得到它？所以nth_element将是那个答案的一部分。它也进行分区，它让你的序列保持分区状态。所以这是一个非常有用的属性，可以被利用。所以如果你试图收集一系列统计数据，比如如果你在图形领域，你想要的不仅仅是中位数，你想要像10%标记、40%标记、50%、90%处是什么，对吧？你想要采样一组范围。你可以通过从nth_element开始来做到这一点
for whatever element is roughly in the middle, and then recursively partitioning, yeah, with nth element. And you can gather a set of statistics very quickly from a large sequence of numbers. So it comes up a lot. It's one of the most underutilized. And a lot of times where I see people sort, it's like, oh, you didn't need to sort. You know, you just needed nthelmin. Right.
对于任何大致在中间的元素，然后递归地进行分区，是的，用nth_element。你可以从大量的数字序列中非常快地收集一组统计数据。所以它经常出现。它是最未被充分利用的算法之一。很多时候我看到人们排序，我就想，哦，你根本不需要排序。你知道，你只需要nth_element。对。
Yeah. People should, in general, think about, and there's multiple algorithms in that kind of sort hierarchy, right? So stable sort is at the top, then sort and partition, then end element. Yeah, or partial sort might be in there, but there's a range of power there, right? And we should be picking the least powerful thing to solve the problem in general. Yes. The fastest algorithm is usually the one with the fewest guarantees. And so think about what problem you actually need solved and then select accordingly. And, you know, it's just like the number of times I see people reach for a map when sort and lower bound would have been the obvious better choice.
是的。人们通常应该思考一下，在那种排序层级中存在多种算法，对吧？所以稳定排序处于顶端，然后是排序和分区，接着是nth_element。是的，或者部分排序可能在里面，但是这里有一系列的能力范围，对吧？我们通常应该选择最不强大的工具来解决问题。是的。最快的算法通常是保证最少的那个。所以思考一下你真正需要解决的问题，然后相应地选择。而且，你知道，就像我看到人们在可以使用sort和lower_bound时却去用map的次数一样，那显然是更好的选择。
People tend to use a shotgun where a scalpel would suffice. Wow. This has been absolutely phenomenal. We'll do this again at some point because this was amazing. Links for everything we mentioned in the show notes. And I know, Sean, we have to let you run. So we'll say thank you. And until next time and to my new co-host as well, Ben.
人们倾向于用霰弹枪，而手术刀其实就足够了。哇。这绝对太棒了。我们以后还会再做一次，因为这太神奇了。我们提到的所有内容的链接都在节目说明中。而且我知道，Sean，我们必须让你走了。所以我们要说谢谢。直到下次，也对我的新联合主持人Ben说声谢谢。
Yeah. Thank you, Sean. Hey, thank you both. Be sure to check these show notes either in your podcast app or at ADSP, the podcast.com for links to anything we mentioned in today's episode, as well as a link to a get up discussion where you can leave thoughts, comments and questions. Thanks for listening. We hope you enjoyed and have a great day.
是的。谢谢你，Sean。嘿，谢谢你们俩。请务必在你的播客应用中或在ADSPthepodcast.com上查看这些节目说明，获取我们今天节目中提到的任何内容的链接，以及一个GitHub讨论的链接，你可以在那里留下想法、评论和问题。感谢收听。希望你喜欢，祝你有美好的一天。
I am the anti-brace. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我是反Bryce派。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来留下评论。